[Music]
undefeated german boxer musa yamato you
guys know
oh i know him sounds like he trains with
habib number one oh i thought you're
serious
he just died during a match
i thought he was undefeated
oh he got defeated in the worst way it's
first
k.o
ah dang dude you weren't joking how do
you respond do you think he died how do
you think he died in the match
probably hit the back of his head i
think he's 8-0 i don't know if it's
because i saw a movie but he maybe fell
his head hit the stool wait did we do
another one about a guy dying from like
mma or no uh boxing yeah from like two
weeks i guess i guess a lot of guys died
from boxing a lot of guys recently have
been falling out of the ring
oh i saw that one i always wanted to do
that to somebody
i bet you will too
don't worry i bet you will i
knocked out of the ring with one of your
fights
no no they they fall down but they never
fall out you don't yell out of me
look how bummed he is about that
never fall out
imagine like suplexing somebody over
cage is it because gen z can't stay
within the ring or some [ __ ]
this is mushy muck right here oh so he's
eight no he looks vicious as [ __ ] he
looks scared he died in the beginning of
the third round is that his like size oh
in the fight did he just like faint
during the fight yeah i don't know if
you guys could see this did it get
knocked yeah how did he die did he get
hit did he just collapse heart attack um
like these fighters if they do like hard
water cuts
then they don't have that much fluid
between their brain and their skull
that's why i think you guys should do
electrolyte yeah i believe you yelled at
me for that it's like oh yeah because
ron is notorious for [ __ ] the
craziest water cuts yeah hey ron you're
notorious for that i just got food
poisoning oh you did try this oh man i'm
surprised you're here today i was puking
till five in the morning bro ron will be
like
ron fights like 1 35 and then like two
weeks before i'm like how have you guys
like 180 or something i'm like what the
[ __ ]
let's not announce that to the world
and you cut that mainly by just not
drinking water mostly water yeah holy
[ __ ] wow what is it you drink uh like
gallons of water right like yeah water
load yeah two gallons a day what's the
protocol so if you're so you say you
have to make weight on friday fights on
saturday what's your water diary on
sunday
sunday people do that that's actually an
option really yeah you can get a
laxative and you guys freaking
out a bunch of feels like freaking 10
pounds but when it comes time to fight
don't you feel weak because i feel weak
after i puke and piss all day there's a
there's an art to it so so what do you
do and what is
what's the right way to do it
practice is like 10 like if you find it
at 135 up to 15 yeah
should it be higher than 10 of your
weight class the the dangerous part is
the lighter of the weight class you are
the more dangerous it is because there's
you're smaller so
15 for a 200 pounder is different from a
15 for a 135 pounder relative 15 for
someone's 200 pounds um
it's like 30 pounds
which is normal like kamara usman
cutting to 170 that's pretty normal but
30 pounds for 135 pounder right it's
much more jurassic yeah like way harder
because nobody messes with percentage
everybody talks about pounds yeah so
when you're supposed to cut weight for a
fight is there any rules where they're
like oh you have to cut it
like in this way and so that you don't
die they start to do that now yeah it's
there's a lot more science-based weight
cutting now like we have like a lot of
guys out there that are like more
experts in it you know what do you do
though what's your style i do i make
sure i'm within 10 or 15 15 of my fight
with
15 15 20.
supposed to be ten you can push it up to
like 15 they say like that's max max max
um
and that's a matter of just like if i
want to enjoy life more if i want to
enjoy life less i'll be 10 and i'll be
shredded like my last fight i was 15 you
could tell because on fight day i looked
like i
i had a dad bod like i had zero abs i
was still knocked down yeah you still
had that dad power i didn't look like
still got him butterbean got a
championship though that looked more
like a fedora fedor fedor fedor and
melanie and anko which is like he's he
was not cut then fedor
versus like get nervous talking about
this
um whereas in other fights um
i was like shred i was like ooh it
looked like a fighter how do you feel
do you feel different though between the
10 to the 15 you've in performance do
you feel like no i mean anybody that
cuts weight they're already gonna have a
dip in performance no matter what
there's
if you wanted to see people perform at
their best they would abolish freaking
weight cutting yeah for real it is in
like all federations do they not allow
you to do ivs afterwards yeah you're not
supposed to but everybody still does oh
for sure so they could get vitamins yeah
like after the weight they don't allow
it oh because it's uh it's it's cheating
right here you're not supposed to cut
cut that much weight they there's they
don't want you to cut weight but
everybody cut weights cuts weight
anyways and then they don't actually use
the ivs but there's actually no test for
it so everybody still does it you can go
to your hotel room yeah everyone's
trying to like get that edge everybody's
trying to get an issue but i think i
think california they do the hydration
before yeah they do a check now but what
happened is so they make you cut weight
and then you can't gain more than 10 of
your scheduled fight weight or actually
your weigh-in um
before the fight so they weigh you in
again now what people are doing now is
they're cutting away twice which is even
more dangerous
and the reason why you cut away the
first place is so you fight people your
own size or you're bigger but what
happens if i don't cut weight i end up
finding someone like bart size yeah the
point is it's like let's say someone
doesn't uh he's actually closer that way
so he fights at 135 and then when he's
in the ring he might be 145. the guy
that knows how to rehydrate might be 170
so during the fight like you're carrying
the 170 guy and it literally feels like
you're fighting someone that's way
bigger than your weight class like the
size difference is fast it's like the
technique is a big issue but if you have
someone leaning on you and then you
start getting a pump in your arms then
your arms aren't punching as fast he
keeps grabbing nick someone's small like
this someone puny like this
yeah
small and [ __ ]
twizzler
do a demo
maybe that's what happened here so
here's this video he's dehydrated this
is the beginning of the third round he
needs pedialyte
he needs electrolytes
all day this one's electrolyte oh i stay
lit bro right here on this on this uh
right side of the screen
they're about to start the third round
do you have this enough 4k
oh
no he knocked himself out oh wow heart
attack you called it bro
he died from a heart attack oh my god so
his heart wasn't like crazy that's crazy
that could be a lot of things right like
yeah a lot of things maybe like if he
was on steroids and caffeine big water
cut and pre-workout can you do
pre-workout no that's some crazy shot
that's such a bad idea does being on a
heavy water cut like drastically
increase the risk of heart i think
increases everything it is so bad for
you you you feel like and wrong gonna
test this because you've had how many
weight cuts have you done in your life i
probably uh over 30 yeah yep you know i
i feel like i lose a year to my life
every time i do a weight cut and every
time you step on the scale to weigh in
you feel like you're on death's door
like you feel like you're gonna [ __ ]
die so when they do the weigh-ins and
then they're all acting tough both of
them are really tired they're faking
crying inside outside like inside like
it's perfect it's poker face yeah it's
real poke and they smell it's pokey
they're like they smell yours like so
dehydrated if you shower it'll reabsorb
it you know what i mean that's how
dehydrated you are you're just like a
sponge yeah so i've i've cut for power
lifting before like one of my most
stupidest cuts i think i was trying to
make 165 again and then i was already
like i'm like 190 something and it's to
the point where like
every two hours you're trying to pee
you're just trying to force liquids out
and you're like pushing as hard as you
can it's literally [ __ ] like honey
coming out it's so condensed like slow
like molasses honey right there
yeah you lick it and go
extra i want to put this on pancakes
yeah and then like that's that bart's
beehive yeah you're like oh [ __ ] kind of
smells i've been cutting away for 24
hours right you go take a shower and you
come out and you're like two pounds
every year because your body literally
really all bloated
what did you eat i showered
and then you caught your eyes like what
the [ __ ] are you doing some dudes when
they have really hard weight cuts
they'll get a bag of ice and then just
chew on it and spit it out
like just the outside bag of ice
with the condensation so they could just
like feel a little bit of moisture in
that sensation yeah you'll even spit in
the bottle and it's all foam because
they're so dehydrated but that foam is
like like a quarter of an ounce of a
pound and that's supposed to make a
difference god dude i didn't know it was
that crazy all the way into high school
so like when you're wrestling right oh
yeah you even have less science less
education
so there's it's so normal to see fools
like shave their head on the day of the
meat shave everything huge
yeah like puke for pounds
just to shed weight huh yeah just just
for that little edge well one time i uh
so when you're dehydrated there's less
water brains you're not as
smart right you're much you're like not
operating things don't fire
slower so i was freaking out i weighed
in right before wayne's like oh no i'm
under i'm not under a pound what do i do
i i'm out i try to pee like drip
drip juice like a leafy faucet i try to
poop nothing i'm like i'm gonna and then
sophie i started gag i shoved fingers
down my throat whoa
dude this is the life right i'm like i
gotta make weight
and then i go i go and weigh in and then
i freaking um i'm under like two pounds
oh
[ __ ] but what i didn't realize was um i
was actually on weight i was just like
for whatever reason i thought i was
underweight was it your own scale that
was [ __ ] up or no no i i just it was
just your mind i stood on the scale and
i was on weight but in my mind it
processed that was over oh that was
actually already under like a pound and
a half so you did more i lost a half
pound for nothing oh my yeah and i
thought back i'm like there's no way i
freaking picked two pounds and i was
like oh shoot i was on weight
fudge ron do you ever get really anxious
and like have anxiety about making
weight um no how do you know it's gonna
suck
the weight cutting the the two hardest
parts about fighting are the weight
cutting and waiting and getting locked
in the room before your flight oh wait
the back room it's like being stuck in
prison like you have nowhere to go like
you can't leave because you have a
commissioner following you to make sure
you don't take steroids but you also
need your like your your hype level to
be here right but then you're also all
by yourself you're like what do i do
yeah
the corners is more than the fight like
you have to have a good relationship
with your corner so you can like be seen
have fun talk crap have some
conversations and whatnot otherwise you
just sit there and like do nothing just
like
how long is that how long is that period
six hours six hours make you check in
like six hours before the show starts
especially the last fight
i'm always the last fight of the night
dude i'm just like oh [ __ ] i never knew
that hey main event right here player
main event
can't even eat like a pretzel or
something oh yeah you can eat uh but if
you go pee they follow you they watch
you pee oh you know to make sure you're
not taking how close are they watching
you they're pretty close they're within
touching distance yeah uh i mean
sometimes they'll like put their arms
around me like in a motorcycle
to make sure i was kidding
just over your shoulders like all right
so how are you doing how are you feeling
because i gotta pee over me doesn't look
like there's stories in that stream of
your
i think you're okay
fudge a heart attack
there's so many you know people there's
a lot of drug testing now and it's
harder to pass drug tests but people
still take drugs like it's so bad for
you where was this fight at yeah i
imagine it was regulated it hadn't been
regulated it looks like a whole event
yeah he is german uh
i would assume it was a title fight so
that'd be some somewhat oh turkey all
right so it's probably steroids
[Laughter]
heart attack most likely yeah most
likely
[Music]
you